the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
started in May of 2008 with the release
of Iron Man 1 and it really is an
unprecedented journey it's been
interesting watching Tony Stark evolve
just an emotional residence his
relationship with the other Avengers his
relationship with Pepper Potts his
relationship most importanly with
himself and how that's developed from
film to film has been quite
extraordinary to see Tony get to a point
where he is introspective where he is
thinking about the things that they have
saved over the years have been amazing
he is the heart of the universe
it's just been this magical thing that
occurred this kind of really risky idea
bringing this whole world to life and I
think with Thor yet Hemsworth in front
and there was this very kind of little
sci-fi version of a Marvel picture
Kenichi ohmae he has grown a great
affection for Earth and humans and the
first time we saw him when he was
arrogant that can be this great kind of
strength and knowledge and power with
him but there's also a sort of naive
kind of kid there at the center of it
it's nice to have that contrast and that
mix biggest concern is that their
well-being of this world and he very
much is sort of looking out further into
the universe to make sure that threat
doesn't consume this world as well I
think the most challenging one of all of
them was was cap this kind of guy out of
time and is it too retro or people gonna
get it and with Evans and Johnson the
first time around it was like yes we get
it and you get it you like it initially
I'm just trying to build a foundation of
who this guy is but you feel like you
know the character not first Captain
America film is subtitled the First
Avenger
because that's really what cap is born
out of the technology of the 1940s
frozen and ice coming back into the
present day he then goes into the
Avengers and he realized in a lot of
ways he's the moral backbone of the
Avengers how do we do this as a team
when you have Thor cat the Hulk Iron Man
finally come together in Avengers that
was something new that people had never
seen before there was an idea to bring
together a group of remarkable people
see if they could work together when we
needed them to to fight the battles that
we never could for us that's what in
Avengers movie is all about how are they
gonna react
do they like each other do they hate
each other do they get along they become
instant best friends that is the heart
and soul of an Avengers film as the
universe grows it's really nice to grow
with the characters I have she has a
breeder colony each movie I'm excited by
the idea of reinventing all struggle and
challenge just brings out the best of us
the first Avengers was about them
meeting each other for the first time in
age of Ultron
they're getting to know each other for
the first time there's a real sense of
unity between the Avengers at this point
so there's something to attack my
favorite part about Avengers age of
Ultron is a feeling of ending of an era
in the beginning of another leading to
Captain America Civil War Civil War was
was primarily a conflict between Steve
Rogers and Tony Stark cap went from
being this guy who was built by the
government and his allegiance was to the
government and it was blind you know
allegiance and Tony was kind of always
flipping the bird to the government
doing but he wanted to do and it was
kind of this rogue entrepreneur and and
over the course of these movies now it's
just kind of evolved and the tables are
turned a bit civil war was incredibly an
impactful event that had major
ramifications in the Avengers and in the
Marvel Universe
it's fun to take the characters that
exist to new places and then it's
equally excited to bring in the new
players and that's why things like dr.
strange things like birdies the galaxy
allows you to keep expanding the tone as
you go I think all that just builds like
the sort of mystique and mystery dance
part of every movie that they do there
is just quite a great emotional journey
within the film's what we've seen happen
within the Marvel Universe is this
ever-expanding coterie of superheroes
and I think now we're at the stage where
this universe even within our world is
gots quite crowded and it's just about
to explode into other dimensions I was
shown my legacy the end of the path I
started us on everyone has their
favorite Marvel movie and everyone has a
favorite Marvel world and just to see
all of them coming together it's a
daring act the hell are you guys every
story that Marvel has told since Iron
Man 1 finds a narrative thread in these
next two Avengers movies it is a
culmination of all of that storytelling
with infinity war we're paying off every
little thread and every little tease
that we've had in what will be 18 films
prior to infinity war there's never been
anything like this being able to film
after film teased at a larger story
really building these stories up into a
giant conclusion while at the same time
introducing an entirely new direction
for the future
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie marvel just
dropped that giant promo for infinity
war for their 10th anniversary Kevin
Feige
teased some really important stuff
especially for the stuff that's coming
during phase 4 so let's break it down
and if you didn't know there is a new
round of that Infinity Gauntlet replica
giveaway going on right now all you have
to do to enter just be subscriber or
leave a comment on the video I'll try to
keep this down just because the video is
already pretty long but they're really
big things Kevin Feige talks about
paying off every little thread every
tease that means bringing red skull back
the Celestials the creation of the
universe the origins of the elders of
the universe all these really big
picture things that you didn't get a lot
of during the guardians films obviously
most of us are focused on the infinity
gems like where's the soul gem I just
did a whole video about that but there's
a lot of other hanging plot threads like
Red Skull being ported to the other end
of the universe by the space gem without
any idea of where he's been this whole
time since that first Captain America
film the very literal giant teaser for
Isan the searcher in the other
Celestials trying to wield the Infinity
stones back during the first guardians
film we've got a taste for the origin of
one of the Celestials because ego the
Living Planet is a celestial in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe there were
some references that the Grandmaster
made during thor ragnarok like he said
that Sekar existed in this special
gravity well so the time moved at a
different rate so that on any other
planet he would be ancient just a wink
to the fact that he's one of the elders
of the universe incredibly powerful and
one of the oldest living beings still
alive next to people like the collector
and other Celestials like ego the Living
Planet the creation of the universe also
gets into the origin of the infinity
gems now I'm expecting them to change
the comics a little bit just to simplify
for people that have not read the
Infinity Saga but the actual origins of
the gems as they're described by the
collector during guardians of the galaxy
fragments from a previous reality that
survived the dawn of creation it sounds
a little bit like the way Galactus was
created in the comics now I believe that
Marvel Comics is in the middle of
something that it calls its eighth
firmament the 8th time for a new cosmos
to be born so anytime the universe dies
its heat death it can track
expands in another universe is born in
this big violent explosion so that's
happened eight times in Marvel Comics
obviously the movies simplify things but
the Infinity stones are the remnants of
that previous reality before the Marvel
Universe as we know it now was born in
everything evolved the way life evolves
in the universe so billions of years
later we arrive at today but the
Infinity stones are what's left over
from that previous version of the
universe so you have to imagine that all
of cosmic Power has been siphoned into
these small objects so they very
literally contain the power of an entire
universe which is why Thanos is able to
wield them to change our universe se
sees fit the really cool Easter Egg
about that like I said is that Galactus
was created that way in the comics he
and a ship were alive and witnessed the
death of all reality but he said that he
just mysteriously woke up and he was
still alive evolved into his current
form when the new universe was born and
only knew hunger he became the hunger a
servant of the universe just meant to go
around in garden eat dead things so that
new things could grow in their place
when foggy talks about the entirely new
direction for the future he's talking
about less solo sequels like we saw
during phase 1 phase 2 more team ups
like Thor Ragnarok and spider-man
homecoming more multiverse thank you
very much dr. strange in more crossovers
with the cosmic stories so as of right
now the guardians don't know any of the
earth-based Avengers that will change
during the next two Marvel films and
there'll be a real connection between
those characters and reasons for the
earth-based characters to go into outer
space for future conflicts but let me
know in the comments what is the biggest
plot thread that you're most excited to
see them pay off like are you just
waiting for Red Skull to come back and
find out where he's been this whole time
do you just care about the soul gem so
what will happen next is is they dropped
a whole bunch more cool Thor behind the
scenes stuff there was actually a scene
in Thor Ragnarok where yondu just walked
through the frame and Asgard because he
happened to be on the lot that day so
we'll do a video for that next and I'll
just name the giveaway winner when I
post that but click here for my soul gem
video and click here for my Black
Panther Easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys
tonight
[Music]